and she held up a condom and said you've
done this before right being a liar said
yeah yeah hi I'm jasmine and today I'm
talking about a new show called sex
education which is now streaming on
Netflix this is a new frontier my
sexually repressed friends our chance to
finally move up the social food chain
sex education is about teenagers
experiencing all of their first times
from first kiss to you know their first
times so today I thought it'd be a good
idea to walk around and ask buzz feeders
about their first times let's go he took
me to get burritos on our first day to
make it back to his dorm room to watch a
movie I felt so fart coming on and that
thing was loud oh no I was mortified
yeah all of a sudden he farts and he
says better out than in I always say and
now we're married 10 years later we need
to end this video like that's it
I was 16 at a friend's birthday party
sleepover I was crushing on her like for
the entire year I was like I knew just
wait put my sleeping bag next to you we
kissed and I just remember like wow this
is this is what this feels like I think
I was senior in high school ever that's
how you met people outside of your
school because everyone would be in the
chats and someone was like show me what
you got now so I go oh okay and someone
did a full photo shoot you know because
you had to find the best angle like
that's the key you know she just was
like nice okay during college and we
were on a break so she was staying with
her parents we went to a party and we
came back and it was really late and we
went up to her room and etc afterward I
had to go to the bathroom so I threw in
my boxers then I went on the hallway and
I physically ran into her father Oh
turned on the light and I was just
standing there almost naked and he shook
my hand and introduced him so we go to
this party and like we leave early
together because we were working on a
homecoming float it was like we were
just talking he was sitting on the edge
of my bed and I said have you ever
thought about hooking up with me yeah
and he just kind of paused and got quiet
and said I'm already hard do I want to
tell you about how I lost my virginity
to an Australian with braces no so as
we've heard from all these stories today
we know that times can be awkward and
unplanned for but honestly that's okay
so as you go on and experience your
first times just remember to be yourself
be confident and you're going to get
through it
[Music]